James Corden he's the voice of Big E
he's great in this building up James had
a very busy weekend cuz he was also
riding shotgun
ryuk air it looks like we're in for a
berry carry Christmas on Cordy
we spotted the pop stars shooting a new
carpool karaoke with the Late Late Show
host you may remember she was the first
singer to ever do this segment and it
has nearly 28 million views on YouTube
that's not an accident when no one would
do it before marker we asked everyone I
mean think of any artist in the world
and they all said no Pharrell - James
sported a Santa sweater wild Mariah
paired a red leather jacket with nothing
but a diamond-encrusted drop of lead the
piece won't air until December which
makes us wonder how James managed to
find a Christmas tree to tie in the roof
of his SUV
oh now see how what a fabulous Christmas
present that was have them Raya on it
gets no better than that that's right
well James does have a carpool karaoke
Erin tomorrow night's equal right ok you
don't want to miss this he is riding
with Lady gaga